in the bustling city of Los Angeles
detective Mark Corley finds himself
entangled in a series of extraordinary
events just as he manages to secure the
release of his estranged son Trent from
jail and otherworldly Invasion unfolds
Before Their Eyes the sky is Ablaze with
mysterious blue lights drawing in a
significant portion of the City's
population into enormous alien
spaceships fueled by determination Mark
takes charge and becomes the guiding
force for a group of resilient survivors
together they navigate treacherous
underground subway tunnels Desperately
Seeking an escape from the clutches of
the otherworldly Invaders yet the odds
are stacked against them and as they
Forge ahead many of their fellow humans
are ruthlessly snatched away or
tragically lose their lives among the
survivors are mark his son Trent Audrey
a Transit operator and an enigmatic
homeless man known as Sarge remarkably
Sarge possesses an immunity to the
alluring blue light courtesy of his
lifelong blindness with each passing
moment the stakes grow higher propelling
them to seek Refuge at the marina after
witnessing the destruct force of a
nuclear attack upon their beloved City
despite their hopes for Sanctuary fate
takes a cruel twist once again before
they can fully comprehend the perilous
situation the survivors find themselves
abducted into the Colossal Flagship of
the Alien Invaders on board marks
unwavering love for his son drives him
to embark on a Relentless quest to
locate Trent he navigates through a
Labyrinth of Chambers encountering
fellow Survivor Elaine along the way
accompanied by her transformed husband
Jared explains the unimaginable truth
behind his metamorphosis into a
biomechanical alien Soldier
astonishingly Jared has somehow managed
to retain control of his mind amidst his
alien embodiment the group's resilience
is further tested when Elaine who is
only three months pregnant experiences a
rapid acceleration of her pregnancy
resulting in the birth of their daughter
within the confines of the alien
Flagship amidst the ever-present danger
and uncertainty the bonds among the
survivors grow stronger United by their
will to survive and protect their loved
ones they face countless trials within
the alien vessel the challenges they
encounter push them to their limits
testing their resolve and
resourcefulness as they strive to
navigate the alien terrain and Safeguard
their fragile existence they are unaware
of the unimaginable surprises and perils
that lie ahead tragedy strikes as
Elaine's life Fades away during
childbirth leaving Mark and Jared to
Grapple with the weight of their loss
determined to bring an end to the
oppressive alien ship they form an
unlikely Alliance together they devise a
daring plan to sabotage the vessel from
within by planting alien explosives
within the vital control systems but
their path is fraught with Peril in a
harrowing confrontation with the alien
leader Jared valiantly fights but
ultimately meets his demise Mark driven
by unwavering determination manages to
rescue Audrey from the clutches of the
Extraterrestrial threat yet his efforts
come too late to save his own son Trent
who falls victim to a chilling fate the
alien sees Trent's brain implanting it
into another biomechanical monstrosity
of their creation with a heavy heart
Mark Witnesses the dying Jared unleash
an act of self-sacrifice his Valiant act
triggers the destruction of the alien
ship sending it hurtling toward a crash
landing in the remote Countryside of
Laos Mark Audrey Sarge and the newborn
baby narrowly escaped the crumbling
vessel as they look back they witnessed
the spaceship begin to regenerate and
repair itself a haunting reminder of the
everlooming threat that still hovers
above them however their respite is
short-lived as Sarge succumbs to his
injuries leaving the group grieving yet
determined to press forward
coincidentally they encounter sua and
his sister Kanya members of a drug
cartel who have chosen to stand against
the Alien Invaders and local Renegade
ex-policemen Bandits the group forges an
alliance traversing the dense jungle
together in search of safety and answers
amidst their Journey they stumble upon a
remarkable Revelation the human baby
exhibits an astonishing ability to age
at an accelerated Pace growing from an
infant into a three-year-old child in a
mere day sua and Kanye guide the
survivors to a concealed Sanctuary a
clandestine Hideout nestled amidst the
ancient ruins of their Homeland here a
human resistance movement thrives
fighting against the encroaching alien
forces however the respite is
short-lived as the leader of the Rogue
policeman Juana crosses their path in a
tense encounter sua and his companions
managed to disarm and capture Juana
ensuring their continued safety within
the Refuge Harper a skilled medical
officer and former drug chemist steps
forward intrigued by the unique genetic
makeup of the baby girl he delves into
extensive research discovering the
possibility that her blood holds the key
to defeating the aliens once and for all
drawing from the child's precious life
force and the remnants of alien
technology Harper feverishly Works to
concoct a serum that he believes can
break the chains of alien control and
restore the humanity buried within the
biomechanical soldiers during a routine
Patrol Kanye finds herself face to face
with an imposing alien adversary in a
selfless Act of Bravery she leads the
Extraterrestrial creature into an
abandoned Minefield remnants of the
Vietnam War as the land erupts in a
devastating explosion the alien menace
is vanquished however this Victorious
moment proves bittersweet as the
explosion inadvertently reveals the
hiding place of the surviving humans and
the precious baby they protect the alien
ships alerted to their location descend
upon the human stronghold chaos ensues
as the Relentless onslaught of alien
forces descends upon the resistance base
in the ensuing battle lives are lost and
the indomitable Spirit of the resistance
is put to the ultimate test tragically
Harper the skilled medical officer Falls
victim to the merciless Invaders leaving
a void in the ranks of the Survivors
undeterred by the mounting odds Mark
fueled by determination seizes the
opportunity to infiltrate one of the
alien ships armed with the serum he
developed he seeks to transform the
mind-controlling blue light emitted by
the aliens into a red light capable of
liberating the once enslaved soldiers
but before he can unleash his
groundbreaking creation the aliens
launch a fierce counter-attack
ruthlessly tearing away the cannon that
contains the transformative light amidst
the turmoil sua recognizing the
importance of Juana's fighting spirit
sets him free from his captivity urging
him to join the resistance in their
struggle for survival with Newfound
determination Juana Rises to the
occasion ready to fight alongside his
fellow humans joined by Audrey a
steadfast Ally Mark sua and Juana find
themselves standing together the last
bastions of Hope against the alien
Onslaught the resolve is unshaken as
they prepare for a final desperate stand
against the encroaching forces with
every ounce of strength and
determination they confront the aliens
head-on determined to protect their
loved ones and reclaim their freedom the
battle rages on with explosions and
gunfire echoing through the air the odds
are stacked against them but their
unwavering Spirit refuses to yield their
fate remains uncertain as the battle
reaches its climax in the face of
impending doom Mark Audrey sua and Juana
stand shoulder to shoulder United in
their Defiance against the Alien
Invaders with their backs against the
wall they confront their adversaries
head on Trent's mind has been restored
after his encounter with his father and
now he fights back with renewed
determination amidst the chaotic battle
a child manages to fix the
malfunctioning Canon Trent seizes this
opportunity and uses the Canon to
eliminate the alien leader causing a
brilliant red light to burst forth
symbolizing The Liberation of the
biomechanical Soldiers with Earth saved
from impending doom Audrey names the
brave girl Rose in honor of Mark's
deceased wife fast forward 10 years Rose
has blossomed into a fully grown adult
and assumed command of an alien ship
with Trent serving as her loyal second
in command United they lead the
liberated biomechanical soldiers and
humans in a daring assault on the alien
ships surrounding the moon including the
massive Mothership Rose and her forces
launch a final decisive blow against the
mothership explosions Ripple through the
alien vessel signaling its imminent
defeat the once dreaded Flagship is now
at the mercy of Relentless resistance
click on one of the videos on your
screen right now